we have definitely talked about
Seasons to come we're ready to go and
and dive into to more uh more of the
world of The Last of Us no question it
might not be her father she was
how does it feel that you're about to
break everyone's heart in the entire
world I it feels awesome I love it it's
why I do this I'm a sadistic person but
I do I like having my heart broken I'm I
I cry all the time I cry at movies that
nobody else cries at occur at the end of
Deadpool 2. I love that so like I'm I
give myself to these things and part of
the whole function of of watching shows
like this is to feel so much and so I'm
ready for people to feel all the things
I felt when I first played the game and
all these new things that we've created
for the series we stay with the game we
carry the spirit of the game we then
bring more to it whenever a fan of the
game like you says they're getting
something new and beautiful out of the
show that's the best news but if you
haven't played the game I think
everything is going to be fine too it's
made for everybody out there what would
you say to people that you know halfway
to play the game and they're like oh
like is this going to be different for
me am I just walking into something I
already know it is going to be different
and it's also going to be something you
know it's both we have this experience a
lot we don't necessarily recognize when
it's happening but we go to see movies
or watch television shows that are about
things that we already know about like
Chernobyl it blew up
the Titanic sank we still go to the
movie because it's the relationships
that carry us through and our
exploration of the relationships in the
show I think had a chance to be just
deeper and richer because we have more
time to spend on story
and people who know the game well are
gonna see and feel a lot of new things
we're gonna get more in there and we're
also going to give them the the things
that they would miss if they weren't
there so the I would say this one's
about the journey just like Joel and
Ellie go on a journey the audience goes
on a journey and that's the experience
that matters more than anything else
Fair have so much attachment to Joel
linelli but also to Ashley and Troy who
have embodied them for so long can you
talk about casting Pedro and Bella and
finding them and what works about them
sure Pedro was was kind of an easy one
he responded to the material immediately
and we had such a great conversation
with him and one of the things that came
out right away was that he's I mean we
know he's a tough guy you know he can
carry himself in a movie he's he can be
dangerous but there's this vulnerability
there's a soulfulness there that was so
important for Joel because this is a
broken man who thinks he's closed off
and then he's not Ellie was trickier
because Ellie was portrayed by Ashley
Johnson brilliantly in the game Ashley's
woman in her 20s playing a 14 year old
girl so what you get from the game is
this interesting far more sophisticated
14 year old than you would imagine so
we're looking for an actor who is funny
and uh smart and Dane dangerous but also
emotionally wounded herself and who just
has I guess what Neil and I called
elliness and we saw over a hundred
people and when we saw Bella's audition
it was that's it we're done we got it
she's Ellie and you know I know when you
start looking at things and you think oh
well all I have is this is what Ellie
looks like from the game and
shouldn't she look just like that just
the appearance goes away after minutes
and then it's about the elliness you
know you know who said it is Ashley
Ashley was like that's it she's Ellie
and who else would know better oh I love
that I love that she was part of that oh
that's awesome I was surprised how much
ground the first episode covered and I
was like wow like coming to the story
were you getting and Neil told me that
you guys are doing the complete first
game
um have you guys talked about during
last of us too and kind of beyond that
we have definitely talked about
Seasons to come we obviously need people
to come and watch this show
um you know I think everybody at HBO is
excited about keeping going we want to
keep going so as long as the audience is
there and the desire is there for more
we're ready to go and and dive into to
more uh more of the world of The Last of
Us no question
[Music]
thank you